et concernant l'afrique après demain un
sommet afrique france va s'ouvrir il va
s'ouvrir à montpellier et c'est nouveau
cette année il n'y aura aucun chef
d'état africain
effectivement ce sont des jeunes des
entrepreneurs des artistes des sportifs
du continent qui échangeront demain avec
emmanuel macron pour tenter de
réchauffer les relations avec l'afrique
alors que la france voit son influence
de plus en plus contestée alors comment
ce sommet est il perçu sur le continent
africain notre reporter lit la femme
ouzou est parti à la alors à la
rencontre de personnes à abidjan ont
regardé un énième sommet une opération
de communication de la pure cosmétique à
voici quelques qualificatifs entendu ici
à propos de ce sommet afrique-france ces
étudiants ivoiriens que nous avons
rencontré déplore que l'avenir politique
économique et même militaire semble
toujours se discuter en france et
surtout il reste très sceptique quant à
la volonté du président français de
dépoussiérer les relations franco
africaines le problème des africains
doit se régler par les africains la
france ne pourra jamais jamais réglé le
problème des africains
quand tu as mal j'étais débrouillard
aigle sur mal toi cela phrase ne viendra
que pour ses intérêts
voyez vous même ici lui d'abord réticent
ici ouais de leur pays si on ferme la
porte complètement peut-être on n'est
pas en quoi mes yeux de faire les choses
de nous mêmes voilà donc ça moi soit
réalise aussi je suis ivoirien je suis
africain moi j'aimerais qu'on soit
autonome à 100 % le mois je constate que
c'est peut-être le cas en ce moment donc
on est encore en phase de développement
on va boire et les étapes tout doucement
on peut pas faire peut-être un voire
deux faits s'avèrent compliquées il
s'agit de certains litiges
politique dans allemands eux l'intérêt
ils sont toujours présents en diodes et
ça par exemple les services par exemple
nous avons assisté à plusieurs scènes si
nous sommes en acajou voilà où les dieux
sont venus et a71 gens de l'armée
ivoirienne compéti la ville avoir tendu
ce que l'ami française est sur le sol
vannes intervention militaire francs cfa
ingérence cette jeunesse dresse un bilan
assez négatif des relations entre la
france et l'afrique jusqu'à présent
depuis que moi je suis né depuis je
commence à apprendre concédé les sphère
politique et août j'ai pas vu
la nécessité de l' inde et à fait
français dans la petite variante quand
on regarde les différents sites miniers
de la peau du foie on voit que il y a
plus être aussi des taux qui dirige la
tête de ce cumul est un code il faut
tout en les étudiant es afrique et au
bien désolé les professeurs dans les
universités pour la capacité d'investir
et de diriger sa solitude me niel il
serait bien que l'afrique où la quoi tu
vois se fondent je vais me créée voilà
quand quelque chose de nouveau il
n'appartient qu'à elle au niveau
politique qu'elle a une vision pour les
typiquement africains ou typiquement
ivoirienne vous l'avez entendu de
nombreuses critiques à l'encontre de la
france est le pari d emmanuel macron
elle va s'avérer difficile à relever
pour cette jeunesse ivoirienne il s'agit
avant tout d'établir une relation plus
équilibrée avec la france et surtout un
partenariat gagnant gagnant en
particulier dans le secteur économique